(techno music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History,
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Linda Greenhouse,
who has covered the Supreme Court
for the New York Times for 30 years,
and has just joined the faculty
of the Yale Law School.
Linda, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thanks for having me.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in New York City.
My parents moved out of New York City,
back to my father's hometown
of New Haven, Connecticut
when I was a baby,
so I grew up outside of New Haven.
- And, what was the conversation
like around the dinner table?
Was there discussion of the law,
or is this something that just came
to you later,
an interest in law?
- No,
there wasn't discussion of law.
My father was a doctor,
he and my mother were
interested in public affairs,
so we talked about, you
know, current events,
not like the Kennedy's, not, you know,
I don't wanna exaggerate.
But, no, not law per se.
- And looking back, how do you think
your parents shaped your
thinking about the world?
- Well, I think they had a, basically,
progressive outlook on the world.
They weren't politically engaged,
but they were democrats,
and, you know, I think I
grew up with that, kind of,
basic orientation,
that FDR was a great president.
I guess my first political
consciousness was in the JFK era,
when Kennedy became president,
I was in junior high school,
and I was very taken with him,
and his whole, you know,
what he represented.
And so, that was kinda my
own political awakening.
- Was it natural
that you fall into being
a Supreme Court reporter?
I'm just looking at this early period,
we'll talk about your education--
- Oh no, I mean really,
I think somebody outside looking
at a career path like mine
would say, oh, she spent 30
years covering the Supreme Court
for the New York Times,
this must've been according
to some grand design.
But, I think, like a lot of careers,
it really was quite random.
What I wanted to be was a journalist.
And I think, in part,
because of my fascination
with the young John Kennedy,
and so on, I read The
Making of the President
in 1960, the great Theodore White book,
which was really the first book ever
to get behind the scenes of
a modern political campaign.
And what I took away from it
at the age of 16 or 15 was,
you know, people got paid for
flying around the country,
writing articles about
my hero and, you know,
maybe this was a job
that one could aspire to.
So, what I wanted to be was a journalist,
and what I wanted to be
was a political journalist.
And that's what I started
out being, actually.
- And, before we get to that choice,
where were you educated?
- Went to public school
in Hamden, Connecticut,
and then I went to Radcliffe
College, which is now Harvard,
so I, Harvard I would say.
- Yes, and what did you major in?
- I majored in American Government.
- Aha, so you had the politics bug,
plus the journalism bug.
- Yeah, I mean I, you know,
wasn't, sort of, out
there on the front lines
of anything, I mean, I
wasn't a political activist,
you might say, like a
number of my friends were
in the late 1960s.
But, I was very interested
as then, and as a subject.
- And, what about your skills as a writer,
which are quite good? (laughs)
- Thank you.
- Did that just come naturally
through your education
at Radcliffe, Harvard?
- I think so.
Well, in high school I had teachers
who really prized writing,
and we got a lot of writing in school.
And, I always was working
on the school paper,
and I was editor of the
high school newspaper,
and always did a lot
of writing on the side.
And was an editor of the Harvard Crimson,
the Harvard daily paper.
So, yeah, I would say,
I mean I never took a
course in a formal way
on writing or on
journalism, for that matter,
but, it sorta came.
- And, did you go right into journalism
after your graduation?
And, what did you cover?
- Yes, I was one of the
few people that I knew
that didn't go to graduate school.
I went out in the--
- Lucky you.
- Lucky me, I went out in the workplace,
and I was very fortunate
to get hired as an intern
by James Reston, who was then one
of the most famous newspaper
columnists in the country.
James Reston, of the New York Times,
had his own, kind of, clerkship program,
that he actually had modeled
after a Supreme Court clerkship,
where he would take a kid every year,
out of college, from a
college newspaper background,
and they would get to work with him,
doing research for him,
doing whatever, learning the business
at his side for one year.
And then, typically get a chance
to have a staff tryout
at the New York Times.
And so, that's what happened to me.
- And what do you think
you learned from him?
Because he was a unique
figure in American journalism,
and some might say that we
don't see as many columnists
like that these days.
- Oh, he was a unique figure in many ways,
and in fact, my years
experience with him was unusual
among the 20 or 30 young people
who had the chance that I had,
because the year that I
worked for him, actually,
we were not in Washington,
which was his home base.
There were some kind of
internal political crisis
at the New York Times,
I don't even know exactly what it was,
but he became, just at the
time that I was graduating,
to go to work for him,
he became executive editor
of the New York Times,
for that one year.
So, his base of operations moved
to New York, and he
kept writing his column,
and I kept doing research
and handling column-related
chores for him.
But he was also running the newspaper.
So, he had a staff of grownups
that were working for him,
and, you know, I didn't
have anything to do
with that side of it.
So, you know, but what I got
was a kind of a ringside seat
at the internal workings of the newspaper.
So, I certainly learned a lot.
- And, Reston, as I think back,
was somebody who was kind of
at the center of the center which existed
at that time in American politics.
- Yes he--
- Did you experience any
of that, in the sense of
getting the impression
of the way American politics worked,
national politics at the New York Times,
in what must have been a different era?
- Well, it was the Vietnam era.
We're talking--
- It was coming unraveling,
a bit--
- That's right.
We're talking 1968,
1969, it was the election
of Richard Nixon.
The cities were burning.
Washington was filled with demonstrations.
It was a very--
- So, it was after then,
after the period
that I was describing.
- It was a very tumultuous time,
and it was disturbing to him,
because he was a man of the establishment,
you might say.
And, things weren't supposed
to work the way they worked.
Although, when I say establishment,
I mean, he was no fan of Richard Nixon,
and in fact, that was
my first election, 1968.
In those days you had to
be 21 in order to vote.
And, I remember I was very dismayed
about the course of politics,
and, you know, Hubert
Humphrey didn't seem to me
to embody the kind of change,
you might say in today's
parlance, that I wanted.
And I said, oh I don't know,
maybe I'll just vote for Nixon.
And I remember he growled at me,
and he said, Greenhouse,
you are voting for Humphrey (laughs).
Yes, Sir.
So, you know, he was a
person of strong views.
But, you know, what I got
to witness at his side,
was he worked really hard.
And, he was always on the phone,
he was always talking to people.
He wasn't one of these pundits
that would sort of sit in an ivory tower
and talk to himself.
And, I remember one thing
that he told me, he didn't
give me a whole lot of advice,
he was very busy running the newspaper,
but he did make an observation
that really stuck with me,
which is that,
don't be afraid to ask questions
while you're interviewing
or reporting, or you're
at the scene of an event,
because if you're too
shy, or feel too inhibited
to ask the question then,
and you sit down to write the story,
that's when you really
need to know the answer,
and then it's too late.
So, always get your questions out there,
and always try to learn more than 100%
of what you're going to have
to disgorge in your writing.
If you're just at that 100%,
and you have no reserve,
you're on pretty thin ice.
And of course, if you know less than 100%
of what you need to know,
you're really in trouble.
So, I carried that with
me into my later career,
and always did try to go the extra mile,
and learn more than I knew I was going to
be pressed to know in the,
just in the context of
the daily journalism.
- Your first assignment was what?
Once you left being at Reston's side?
- I was a reporter on general
assignment on the metro staff
at the Times for, oh,
maybe about six months,
and then they sent me to
one of the suburban bureaus,
West Chester County,
a suburban county just
north of New York City.
And, I stayed there for almost four years.
- And then, did you go
to Albany after that?
Or, yeah--
- Yeah,
then I had a little stint on
what they called night rewrite.
So, I would come in every
day, late in the afternoon,
and just do whatever.
You know, don't forget,
those were the days when there
was actually a news cycle.
And, you know, the paper
came out in the morning,
and that's when people got their news.
It wasn't the 24/7 news
cycle that we have today.
So, I covered some very trivial things,
I covered some very major things.
I remember one of the major
things was the coup in Chile,
the murder of Salvador Allende.
And, we didn't have an obit
of Allende in the files,
because there was no anticipation
that he was soon to die.
And so, I remember
having to cobble up that,
right on deadline, and
recount the whole history,
the modern political history of Chile,
using whatever resources
we had immediately at hand.
And I'm not talking about
Google or the internet.
I'm talking about, you know,
clip files with hard copy.
So, it was very exciting,
and I learned a lot,
and I really liked it, actually.
It was fabulous training.
So, I did that for, mm,
maybe about 3/4 of a year,
and then got the chance to
go to the Albany bureau,
covering the state legislature.
- And, what was it like
covering state politics?
I mean, what did you learn
from that experience?
Because, just thinking about it,
it must've been very different
from covering the Supreme Court.
- Oh well, I mean, any
young reporter should try
to work covering a state capital.
Because, just on the simplest level,
it's fantastic good fun.
I mean, it's a three-ring circus,
no matter what the capital is,
if it's Sacramento, if it's Austin,
and Albany, certainly was that.
So, that was just, you know, pure fun.
But, on the substance,
those were the years, in
the mid to late 1970s,
the years of the New
York City fiscal crisis,
which folks here may not remember,
but, the fiscal--
- We have our own (laughs).
- You have your own, and
now the country has its own,
since we're talking in September of 2008.
But, back in the 1970s,
New York City was technically bankrupt.
And, this was an amazing evolution,
and the question was what to do about it,
and it had taken years for
that crisis to mount up.
And it took years for it to be resolved.
And, I was there on the
resolution side of it.
So, it was really fascinating.
Now, New York had a really
outstanding governor, Hugh Carey.
The first democratic governor
in New York in, I think,
16 years, right after the
Rockefeller era ended.
And, he didn't know anything
about municipal finance,
and neither did anybody.
But, they knew they had
to learn it really quick.
And so, they called on some
of the smartest people on Wall Street.
Felix Rohatyn is a name
people might recognize,
was just a young investment banker,
he was brought in.
And everybody put their
shoulder to the wheel
and worked out a way of
getting through this crisis.
And I was really on the
front lines covering it
on a daily basis.
So, I learned the substance
of municipal finance,
I learned about politics.
I was exposed to some
fascinating personalities,
and it was just a great experience.
- Would it be fair to say
that covering the Supreme Court is more
like an academic exercise
than covering state politics?
In the sense that you're looking
at decisions, cases out there
from an office (laughs)?
- Well, I mean,
it certainly doesn't have
the face-to-face quality
that covering a political institution has.
But, I think what my
Albany experience gave me
was a bit of a sense of a court,
the Supreme Court as an institution
that's inherently a part
of our political process.
And so, when you say academic, I mean,
it may have a sort of an academic feel,
that you're sitting and
reading most of the time,
instead of, kind of, mixing
it up with the news makers.
But, I think what I tried to bring
to my reporting on the court
was a sense of context,
and a lot of times it's political context,
because Supreme Court cases
don't just drop out of the sky.
They come out of something,
they come out of some conflict in society
that leads to litigation,
that leads to lower court decisions
that leads directly to the Supreme Court.
And I tried to maintain a sense of that,
and give my readers a feel for that.
- Right.
So I guess, what I was
making was a distinction
of how you gather the information,
versus the actual writeup, and so on.
So, in Supreme Court work,
you're following the cases, obviously,
that are out there in the country,
that are coming before the court.
But, are you doing a lot of interviewing?
- No, I'm not doing a lot of interviewing,
but I'm following more than the cases.
I'm following the, kind
of, political landscape
to understand the context
in which these cases are occurring.
- Yes.
And, you've written in some
of, both in the Blackmun book
and in your articles about
the dynamics within the court,
which I found interesting.
In the Blackmun book, you wrote
about the court's processes.
You said, there was a fluidity
with which coalitions formed
and shifted, and formed again,
depending on the issue.
It was extremely foolish ever
to write off a likely opponent
or to take a potential ally for granted.
With so many cases under
consideration at once,
a colleague might, at any given moment,
be both opponent and ally.
So this was a dynamic that you
came to see over the course
of your term.
Now, talk a little about that.
- Well, I think that was,
I was writing about a
period in the 1970s and 80s,
but it's still true today,
I mean, in the, kind of,
small-group dynamic of nine people,
you know, you can't take
anybody for granted.
And, what happens at the court, you know,
somebody gets assigned to take a try
at crafting a majority opinion,
and, you know, that's
just taking a crack at it.
And, nobody can speak
for the court unless four
other people sign their name
on what you're circulating.
So, I think, for instance,
a lot of people ask me,
well, after Bush against
Gore, the 2000 election case,
which was so hard fought, and
so bitterly dissented from
by the four dissenters,
you know, how could
they get back together?
How could the court function?
And, you know, I always answer,
they knew they had to get back together.
Because it's not like Congress,
where, you know, you can be part
of a caucus that goes off and sulks
in the cloak room until things
start breaking your way.
You don't have that luxury
at the Supreme Court,
you've gotta get onto
the next case pronto.
And you've gotta be able to count to five
if your gonna get anything done.
So, I think that is a basic dynamic
that keeps the court going,
even in a period where there
are pretty sharp disagreements,
and the court is quite polarized
on a lot of important things.
- And, you have friendships
that cross, you know,
intellectual barriers, so to speak.
I believe Ginsburg is a friend of Scalia,
and in the case of Blackmun,
he had been close to Burger,
but over the course of years,
they went different ways.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
friendship, or lack of friendship,
could be, sort of, you know,
too easily exaggerated.
I mean, I think they
all try to be collegial,
they're all grownups.
But, I don't think where
the rubber meets the road
in terms of how you're
gonna vote in a case,
it's not, again, it's not
like a political branch,
where there would be vote
trading or, you know,
you're a good guy, I'll
support your project today,
on the expectation
that you'll support my
pet project tomorrow,
it's not like that.
You just vote how you think
the case should come out.
- Let me show your Blackmun
book, we'll get into it,
Becoming Justice Blackmun.
It's an intellectual biography,
a biography and the story
of his life on the court,
and, actually, his life even before that.
And, from this book I got the sense
that law clerks can be very important.
I mean, the justice is still in charge,
but often they are a kind of a source
of stretching the intellectual boundaries
of what's in the judges mind.
Although they don't necessarily,
I'm not saying they decide the decision,
but they help stretch a
justices mind, is that fair?
- Well, I think that was probably true
in Blackmun's case, I'm not
sure it's true in every case.
It's a very intimate relationship,
the justice and the law clerks.
Each justice has four law clerks,
and they serve for a year.
And they are the best and the brightest
of the recent law school graduates.
They've all been law review editors,
and they've all clerked on some
other court before they come
to the Supreme Court.
So, the justices who
use them well, I think,
use them as a source
of intellectual energy
and refreshment,
because, you know, you're
up in your ivory tower
as a Supreme Court justice,
and you're kind of, you know,
not necessarily in the mix of, kind of,
the current ferment over the
constitution, or whatever.
So, the reason they use this system,
and not every court does,
I mean, there are courts that have,
not the federal courts,
but there are state courts
or whatever, who have a cadre
of professional clerk research staff,
and they don't turn over every year,
and that's another model.
But the reason
that the federal clerks
use this clerkship model is
there's an affirmative
benefit from it to the judges.
- Has, do you think that the
way the court is perceived
by society has changed a lot
in the course of your career?
Has the court become
politicized at a new level?
Or does this just periodically happen
in American history, as was
the case in The New Deal?
- Well, I mean, your question seems
to assume that I think
the court is politicized.
- No, I'm asking, I'm just asking.
In other words, as an observer,
I'm not a legal scholar,
looking from afar,
it seems that we've gone
through a recent period
of high politicization.
And, I guess I should
define what I mean by that.
I mean the way the Supreme Court becomes
an object of political concern
in the greater society.
I'm not talking about,
necessarily, the politicization
among the members
of the court, which would
be a different question.
- Well, I started covering
the courts, sort of,
at the long shadow of the Warren court.
And, you now, Richard Nixon came
to national political prominence,
and ran for president in 1968,
running against the Supreme Court.
So, I mean, the Supreme
Court is a very handy target
for politicians.
And that is certainly nothing new.
In fact, I think right now
the political discourse
about the court is at a lower level,
is almost beneath the radar.
I keep waiting for the
presidential candidates this year
to have a good, rip-roaring discussion
about the Supreme Court.
That has not yet occurred,
and it never occurred
in the Clinton years,
although I kept waiting for it then, too.
So, you know, I think the court
can serve political purposes
when a national politician
thinks it's in their interest
to make it, but that
isn't necessarily anything
that's inherent in the court itself
at one period or another.
- You write, let me give you another quote
about the Supreme Court from your book.
Maybe this was from
the book, I'm not sure.
In fact, it is most
often the Supreme Court
that is the follower.
You're talking about it's
relationship to society.
It ratifies or consolidates change,
rather than propelling it.
Although, in the midst of
heated debate over a major case,
it can appear otherwise.
You go on to say,
I'm simply offering my
empirical observation
that the court lives
in constant dialog with
other institutions,
formal and informal.
And when it strays too far
outside the existing political
or social consensus, the
result is palpable tension,
both inside and outside the court.
I believe this actually
appeared in the New York Times,
your farewell--
- Yeah, that was in a kind
of a retrospective piece
that appeared in July.
- Kinda comment on that.
Do you wanna say anything more than that?
Because it's obviously the case
that in particular cases, Roe v. Wade,
which you discuss, because,
in the Blackmun book,
because he, of course, wrote the opinion.
That was a case where the
court may have gone too far,
not in the sense of women's
rights, but in the sense
of the way the society reacted.
- Well, or I would, to be more,
say more current about it,
I mean, on my watch at
the court, certainly,
affirmative action was a big,
was a hot topic.
And the court wrestled with it,
the Bakke case, 1978, was
one of the first major cases
that I covered.
And, you know, ended up
with a four to four to one,
the one in those days was the swing voter
on the court in those
days, Justice Powell.
And that continues to be something
that the court hasn't
come to a real consensus
of the most recent
affirmative action case,
the case is from the
University of Michigan,
from about five years ago,
was sort of the last word,
and bought the court and
bought society some time.
But, that's been a real pressure point.
And so, when I say
the court is most comfortable
following the existing consensus,
and when it feels that
it's getting out in front,
gets, there's a kind of
an institutional tension.
I think what I had
in mind was the affirmative
action line of cases.
On abortion, I mean, what's so
interesting when you get back
in the actual papers that lead to,
that informed the courts consideration
of Roe against Wade in 1971, 72, 73,
January of 73, the
opinion finally comes out,
is the court was fairly clueless
about how that opinion was gonna fly.
The court didn't really
feel itself out in front.
In fact, I think the seven justices
who signed the majority opinion felt
that they were ratifying
what had come to be the,
at least the elite
consensus in the country.
And, they were right,
there was Gallup polls
that backed this up, that people had come
to think that the regime
of criminal abortion laws,
and throwing doctors in jail
for performing abortions was,
had actually created a
public health crisis.
Because women were
having abortions anyway,
as they always were, and always would,
but they weren't safe.
And so, it was an effort
to kind of just bring that whole
area into the 20th century.
- You talk a great deal about that case
in the Blackmun book,
'cause of course he wrote the opinion.
And let's talk a little about that,
because it actually conveys a sense
of the way personality comes
to play, the background
of a particular judge, the
fortuna of getting chosen
to write the opinion, and so on.
And, Blackmun had an
interesting background,
because he was appointed
by President Nixon
after President Nixon had failed
in getting two appointments,
Haynsworth and Carswell,
through the senate,
and then he turned to Blackmun,
who was a lifelong
friend of Justice Burger.
- Chief Justice Warren Burger, right,
they had grown up together
in Saint Paul, Minnesota.
- So the expectation would be
that Blackmun would tilt
toward the conservative side,
not based on his legal background,
but just the politics.
- Well, based on his
legal background, too.
I mean, when the Nixon
administration was considering him,
a young lawyer
in the Justice Department
named William Rehnquist
was given the assignment
of checking out Harry Blackmun's record
on the Eighth Circuit, the
Federal Court of Appeals
that was based in, that
is based in Saint Louis,
to make sure he was
conservative enough, and he was.
I mean, there was very
little in his record
as an appeals court
judge that would indicate
that he was gonna end up 24 years later
as the most liberal member
of the Supreme Court.
And, when he started out on the court,
he was quite conservative.
I mean, the first big
constitutional controversy
that he confronted in his
time at the Supreme Court,
it was not abortion, it
was the death penalty.
And, in 1972, when the
court, in the Furman case,
held unconstitutional
every death penalty statute
in the country, Blackmun dissented.
And, a couple years later,
in the Pentagon Papers case,
when the court held
that the government did not have the right
to block the publication
of the Pentagon Papers
by the New York Times
and the Washington Post,
Blackmun dissented.
So, he was a quite conservative
justice when he started out.
- But, there's some, and
I should say, not but,
there was some fascinating
items in his background
which really stand out in your
wonderful judicial biography,
I guess you would say.
And that is that for 10
years after graduating
from the Harvard Law School,
he was chief counsel for the Mayo Clinic,
which kind of exposed him
to the world of medicine
and legal problems
that arise thereof.
- Well, he loved medicine.
He had considered going to medical school.
And the only reason, actually,
he chose law school
over medical school was,
it was cheaper and it had
fewer requirements to get in.
So, he was really drawn to medicine.
He practiced with a big
law firm in Minneapolis
that had as a client the Mayo Clinic.
And he actually did a lot of tax work
for the Mayo Clinic.
And so, then he, the
Mayo Clinic asked him,
was setting up an in-house position
as general counsel, and
they offered him the job.
And he decided to leave private practice,
and go work full-time at Mayo.
And, you know, his job wasn't,
obviously wasn't medical,
though, sort of, malpractice
and medical issues came up.
But, he would go on the grand
rounds with the Mayo doctors,
you know, as they went around,
you know, with the patients.
And he loved it and
found it very fascinating
and fulfilling.
- And, what is fascinating in this story,
as it unfolds, is when
the case was decided,
the justices, or at least
Blackmun was focused
on the liability of doctors
who performed abortions.
There was a great concern
that the whole malpractice issue,
and I guess even criminal statutes
that some states had against abortion,
was a real threat to the
practice of medicine.
And then, in addition, if
the court didn't decide,
then judges were lacking guidance on how
to respond to such cases.
The bottom line being
that you're suggesting
that the concern about
women, and their situation,
was kind of a third-order
priority in making that decision.
Is that a fair reading
of what you're writing?
- Well, yeah, and I
think it's the only way
to read what actually occurred.
I mean, this isn't just
my thought about it.
There's a lot of anachronistic thinking
about Roe against Wade.
Roe against Wade preceded
the modern women's movement.
And at the time it made its
way to the Supreme Court,
in the beginning of the 1970s,
the court didn't have, kind of,
sex discrimination or
women's rights, in mind.
It really didn't.
And, Roe presents, and if people read it,
and of course most people are happy
to talk about it without
ever having read it,
but if people actually
sit down and read it,
they will find in it a
doctor's bill of rights,
not a women's bill of rights.
And, of course, doctors were the ones
who were being criminally prosecuted.
Women weren't being prosecuted
for having abortions.
The crime was to perform an abortion.
So, it was doctors who were on the line,
and there had been a
number of cases, you know,
there had been a German measles epidemic,
and doctors wanted to perform
for their patients what were then known
as therapeutic abortions,
because these fetuses would
be predictably badly damaged
by the German measles.
There had been the thalidomide episode,
where a woman famously left the country
and went to Scandinavia
to have an abortion.
And so, change was in the wind,
and the leading medical organizations,
like the American Medical Association,
the American Public Health
Association, and so on,
that had, for decades,
had a position against
legalizing abortion,
had very recently changed their position.
And so, the courts consideration
of this issue was reflecting those trends
and those observations, and
what they had in mind was,
we've got a public health issue,
and we're treating it as
resolving a public health problem.
- And so, what your saying is, in a way,
that they're focus was such
that they didn't realize
that they were moving ahead
of society in the way that
ultimately became the case,
in terms of the almost immediate reaction.
And you tell the story
that Blackmun has a speaking engagement
after he delivers the majority opinion,
and there were pickets,
and he, opposing the decision,
and he was taken aback because he didn't,
he didn't understand the politics yet.
- Right, well, you know,
when you say the court was
moving ahead of society,
I actually don't think so.
I think the court was pretty
much where society was.
What happened was, it became a wedge issue
in the hands of a political movement
that was happy to hitch its
wagon to that particular star.
And that's what happened,
and it got away from the court.
But, at the time the court ruled,
there were, you know, polling,
and it was clear that there
was a public consensus
that the question of abortion was
between a woman and her
doctor, and not for the state.
- And, in the decision,
there was an opening
for the notion that at some
point a state interest came
into play, when you
considered the whole term
of the pregnancy.
So, but, the decision itself was based
on the penumbra of privacy
that they found in the ninth amendment.
- Well, yeah, in part, in
the fourteenth amendment,
and so on.
But, yeah, I mean you're talking
about the trimester system,
where the court said, and, you know,
lots of people have criticized, kind of,
the trimester aspect of Roe.
But when you think about it, you know,
it's not a foolish concept
to say that it's a balancing
of the state's interests
and the woman's interests,
and once a fetus is viable,
in the third trimester,
the state's interest in
the life-preserving aspect
becomes a good deal stronger
than at the very beginning.
I mean, we could debate
the kind of philosophy
of this, but certainly
what the court had in mind was
that in the first trimester,
when abortion is notably safer
than carrying a child to term,
the state really has no interest
in preventing abortion.
And it's only interest is making
sure that it's done under,
you know, safe, medically
appropriate conditions.
In the second trimester, the
state's interest grows a bit,
because abortion becomes
more dangerous medically.
And, finally, in the last trimester,
the state's interest is pretty strong.
But, still cannot trump
the interests of the woman
in preserving her own life and health.
And that's still our law today.
- And, after the decision,
the political movement,
the anti-abortion political movement,
created a political context
where various states began taking,
I think you call it guerrilla action,
against the opinion by
looking at the various ways
in which the abortion could
be obstructed or prevented.
Talk a little about that,
because it's a classic case
where the Supreme Court
reaches a decision,
you're saying it really
reflected the views
of society, but then the
turbulence came, as you say,
when a political movement emerged
to take advantage of this.
- Yeah well, I mean it's
still going on today.
It's going on this very day.
So, what you had were states,
I mean, Missouri was a major
one, Pennsylvania, Ohio,
Illinois, where they
couldn't prohibit abortion.
But, they could create obstacles
and make women and their doctors jump
through a set of hoops.
And so cases came up about, well,
do you need your husband's consent?
The court said, no, you can't
require the husband's consent.
Well, how about the husband's notice?
The husband has to be on notice.
No, you can't require that either.
Well, doctors have to read
women a certain script
to make them think again, or think harder,
or go home, or whatever.
And initially the court
said, no you can't do that.
Then the court, a more conservative court,
said yes, you can do that to some extent.
There's a case making its
way to the court right now,
from the Eighth Circuit from South Dakota,
where doctors are required to
read a truly offensive script
before going ahead with the abortion.
And it's being challenged
as an infringement
on the first amendment rights of doctors,
compelled government speech.
So, these things are still going on,
and they have generated dozens of cases,
whether this obstacle or
that obstacle presented,
in the courts analysis,
a quote, "undue burden" on
the woman's right to abortion.
- Are you surprised by the litmus test
that abortion has become in the politics
of appointments to the Supreme Court?
Are there other cases of
a narrow focus like this
in the history of the court?
- Well, I think there are in the sense
that you certainly
couldn't nominate somebody
to the Supreme Court that, for instance,
thought Brown against
The Board of Education
was a bad decision.
And, there was a time when, you know,
that was, people had to be
pretty clear about that.
I think what's different about abortion is
that society, or at least,
kind of, civilized society,
pretty quickly settled
on Brown against Board
as a correct decision.
But, yet, there's obviously, as we know,
still a number of people
that think Roe against Wade
was the opposite of a correct decision.
So, it's still, it remains a battleground.
So, you know, I guess it's not surprising.
What I think is, um--
- Bizarre?
- Well, kinda self-defeating,
for the Republican party to have this
as a one-dimensional litmus test,
it disables them from considering a lot
of highly qualified
conservative lawyers and judges
who are not necessarily
anti-abortion movement activists.
I mean, that's what
brought us Harriet Miers.
You know, in 2005, when
President Bush felt,
correctly I think, that after
Sandra O'Connor's announcement
that she was going to retire,
it was important to have
another woman on the court.
But, there were very few women
who could pass the
anti-abortion litmus test,
even though there were a number
of superbly qualified
Republican, female judges
and lawyers in the country,
they were passed over immediately.
And the administration basically ran out
of potential nominees.
So, I think that's
self-defeating for them,
but I'm not one of them, so, you know.
- In your book on Blackmun,
you record, through a careful
examination of his papers,
his intellectual growth on certain issues,
how he came to see the
broader context of problems.
And an example here would
be the whole question
of women's rights, which
he didn't perceive,
even though he discussed
the decision beforehand
with his three daughters and his wife,
but he didn't, sort of,
understand the broader context
of women's rights.
But he grew, and that changed.
Do you think that his story tells us a lot
about the way many justices
on the Supreme Court grow
on the court?
Not all, but many.
- Well, that's a good question.
And, of course, these are loaded words,
because you and I can say
grow with, kind of, approval.
Now, on the other side, you know,
that's viewed as a kind
of a liberal, you know,
kind of throw away.
But, it is true that once somebody gets
to the Supreme Court, no
matter where they come from,
they've got to take a
broader look at things.
And things look different up there.
Now, there's been a fair amount
of recent social science research on this.
On justices who changed from
their starting ideology.
And what the current research has shown,
and Blackmun is a paradigm case,
is that justices who come
from outside of Washington,
from beyond the beltway,
without prior experience working
for the executive branch, are
the most likely to change,
to move to the left, to define our terms.
And those who come from inside Washington,
or have prior federal
government experience
are least likely to change.
And, you know, when you think
about it, it makes sense.
Because a move to Washington in mid-life,
Blackmun was 60 or 61
when he came on the court,
had never, didn't have
any Washington experience.
You know, it's very disruptive,
and mind-bending, and mind-opening.
So, it's not surprising that this happens,
and this happened to a lot more people
than just Harry Blackmun.
- Do you think that it's better, well,
let me get your evaluation of the category
of appointees to the court.
Do you think, how do you
evaluate putting lawyers
who also have been in politics
at the state level, or
even at the national level,
as opposed to coming to the court
from a circuit court?
- Well, personally I think
it would be a very good thing
to, sort of, mix it up a little,
and have some politicians on the court.
The court we have now,
every single justice had,
as their immediate past job, service
on a federal court of appeals.
That's unique in the country's history,
that hadn't happened before.
The Warren court, I believe
I'm right in saying,
not only was it headed by Earl Warren,
who had never been a judge of any kind,
three-time governor of California,
but, I think there was nobody
on the Warren court who
had been a federal judge.
Justice Brennan had been a
state judge in New Jersey.
No one had been a federal judge.
And so, you know, that court
had a sort of a grounding
in the political life of the country
that came from that background.
Or if people look at Justice O'Connor,
who had been a state
court judge in Arizona,
but had also been majority leader
of the Arizona State Senate,
and had run for election.
And she was really a kind
of a political animal,
and she brought a sort of
a pragmatic, grounded sense
of what the country needed
to her 20 plus years on the court
that I think was very salutary.
So, I would hope that the next president,
whoever wins the election,
would look outside the box,
and find somebody with
a different background.
- Your on campus as
the Jefferson Lecturer,
and I know you're gonna be
talking about the mystery
of Guantanamo, and that set of decisions.
What is, one gets the sense as
I've read about these cases,
I've read your articles,
and one gets the sense
that the Guantanamo decisions, let's call,
not just the last decision,
it's really about the
court drawing a line,
and trying to judiciously
inform the executive
that it didn't buy into
where it was drawing the line
in the sand.
Is that a fair assessment?
And, the decision seemed
to almost be saying,
you didn't listen to our last decision.
Is that a correct reading?
- Yes,
I think that's an excellent, you know,
25 word or less summary of my, kind of,
long, complicated lecture,
which I call The Mystery
of Guantanamo Bay.
And the mystery is, how can it be
that the Bush administration has
lost case after case after
case in the US Supreme Court,
but yet has never been
ordered by any judge
or any person or body in
a position of authority
to release, against its will,
a single Guantanamo detainee?
This is a mystery, how can this be?
And so, it really is the story
of the administration pushing
and pushing and pushing,
the court drawing first a gentle line,
and then a less gentle
line, and then last June,
two months ago, in the
Boumediene decision,
granting constitutional
rights to habeas corpus
to the detainees.
You know, a firmer line, and it's like,
what part of the rule of
law don't you understand?
It's been a kind of a one-way dialog,
and very unusual in our
history, and very fascinating.
- Is it because of the,
two elements come to mind,
I'm gonna go to your lecture
so I'll know the answer later,
but is it about, one, the
fragility of the coalition
on the court, and also the uniqueness
of this experience that
we all went through
at 9/11, namely that we were attacked
on our homeland by an organization
that isn't a state.
Is that involved?
- Well,
those are elements of the whole picture.
That's not what I focus on.
What I'm focusing on, really,
is the separation of powers element
to the way this has played out.
And, you know, the court,
as we said earlier, the
court is basically a modest,
and quite conservative institution.
So, when the first cases reach the court,
the court rules quite modestly.
Not making a sweeping
constitutional pronouncement,
they just decide what they have to decide.
And what they basically decide
on the first round, in 2004,
is, you know, you bet
wrong when you decided
to put the detainees at Guantanamo,
you bet that this would be
outside the jurisdiction
of the federal courts.
And, you know, it's
functionally the United States.
We exercise complete
power and control there,
it is within the statutory jurisdiction
of the federal courts
to entertain petitions
for habeas corpus.
That's all the court said.
One might think that was enough.
But the administration
basically ignored that,
and kept right on going.
And so, that set in motion a dynamic
where the court, with increasing dismay,
alarm, and I think almost
a sense of disbelief,
kept learning that it's message
was just not being received.
And so, you know, finally the decision
that came down in June of this
year, the Boumediene case,
you know, do we have to
hit you with a two by four?
We mean habeas corpus.
So, it's just been a
fascinating trajectory.
- And, to what extent does
the court, or do we know yet,
have a very different view
of the president's power
vis a vis treaties,
international treaties?
'Cause on the one hand,
in these Guantanamo cases,
it's saying that Article III applies,
from the Geneva Conventions.
But, on the other hand, in
this recent Mexican case,
I don't know if we can mix
these different things,
where they allowed the state of Texas
to do what it's legal process had said,
and said, you know,
put aside the treaties that were involved.
- Well, yeah, I mean, I
don't think those are--
- They're not related, okay
- They're not really related.
I mean the case you're talking
about is the Medellin case,
where the Mexican death row inmate had
not gotten read the rights
that are required under the
treaty that we've signed,
called the Vienna Convention.
What the court held there is
that the Vienna Convention
governs relationships
between the signatory,
among the signatory states,
the countries, and can't
be, is not self-executing
and it can't be invoked by an individual.
So, that was a kind of a
technical reading of the treaty,
a different kind of
international law thing.
- But, then, but what
about the application
of the Geneva Conventions?
I mean, is this a,
well, it's probably a court
that wants to find the narrowest grounds
to make the dec--
- Well, that's right.
Yeah, I mean the court
basically is deferential
and wants the political
branches to figure this out.
And so, what the court said in the middle
of these three cases,
the Hamdan case in 2006,
which was the case about the legitimacy
of the military commissions
that the President had set up
to conduct the criminal
trials of the detainees is,
you've gotta set this
up within the framework
of the Geneva Conventions,
and you've gotta get congressional input.
It can't be just a unilateral
executive decision.
And so, that then went back to Congress,
and Congress did, in the
Military Commissions Act of 2006,
reconfigure the military commissions.
Now, what they also did was
strip the federal courts
of jurisdiction to hear
habeas corpus petitions.
And that's what lead to the next decision.
But, yeah, the court took, you know,
took account of the Geneva
Conventions in that case.
- As you leave the Times, what,
and this program is aired nationally,
what would you like the message
to an audience of not
necessarily, some lawyers
in the audience, but
not the legal community,
what is the lesson you would like
to leave them with about
what you've learned
about the Supreme Court?
Is there a simple way
of putting how we should
understand the court's role
in the evolution of our democracy?
Big question.
- Well, what I ended up,
that retrospective piece
that you referred to earlier,
was with the sort of ironic observation
that, you know, we get
the court we deserve.
And people say to me,
what do you mean by that?
And I mean, you know,
the court requires us
to do the work of paying attention
to what it does, and, you know,
desiring it to reflect the
best that our system has
to display, and I think
what I've come away with is
that, I mean, I respect the
court as an institution,
maybe more than a mere journalist should,
but I do expect, you know, I
hope for the best from them.
And, I think that it takes work
to follow what the court does.
It requires a lot of the
public to really stick with it.
I think good journalism
about the court can enable
the public to do that,
to the extent that a lot of newspapers
and news organizations are cutting back
on Supreme Court coverage.
I think that's a disturbing trend,
but I would say to people, you know,
stick with it, 'cause
it's really important.
And it's important that it be understood,
and that the court, and the presidents
who make the appointments
that make up the court,
be held to account.
- I wanted to read you one quote
from you farewell article,
because you've actually watched a lot
of history during this period
that you've been covering the court.
And, you're talking about, here,
about Sandra Day O'Connor
and Ruth Ginsburg,
and I found this amusing,
but I want you to just,
years later my daughter
bluntly reminded me
that today's young women have the luxury
of taking for granted the
pioneering accomplishments
of Sandra Day O'Connor
or Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
When I observed that I was out of college
before I ever met a
woman who was a lawyer,
your teenage daughter
regarded me with compassion,
face it mom, you've led a sheltered life.
Does that convey the
changes that you've watched,
as you've watched this
important institution--
- Well, in part, and I
guess what, you know,
was kind of amusing
about that is, you know,
I don't think I have led a sheltered life,
I've had a ringside seat at history.
So, you know, I feel very lucky
to have not had a sheltered life.
- And, one final question,
what should we be watching for
as we go through the
presidential election?
Well, first the court, as you said,
is not a topic of discussion.
But, as an informed observer,
what would you be concerned about,
and what would you hope would happen?
- There's a very good book out now,
that I've recommended to people,
it's called The Next Justice,
it's by Christopher Eisgruber,
who's the provost of Princeton.
He's a Supreme Court scholar,
and former Supreme Court law clerk.
And, his point in this book,
it's a book that looks
at the Supreme Court confirmation process,
but he makes an obvious, but
very infrequently made point,
which is that before we get into a debate
about what kind of justice
we'd like on the Supreme Court,
when the next vacancy occurs,
we need to come to some
common understanding
about what is the judicial function?
What do Supreme Court justices do?
What do we expect of the court?
So, I would like to see
that kind of conversation,
and not just the sound
bites about, you know,
I want justices who follow the law
and not make the law.
You know, what does this mean?
It's completely meaningless.
But, really, you know,
understand what we ask
of the court, and what the court does.
And to have a, you know,
the kind of civics education
that I think is kind of missing
in our public discourse.
- On that note, Linda, thank you very much
for coming to Berkeley to
be the Jefferson Lecturer.
And, thank you for being on our program.
- [Linda] And, thank you for having me.
- Thank you.
And, thank you very much
for joining us for this
Conversation with History.
(techno music)